all right first live stream in a very
long time I was looking at the calendar
today and it's been it's been just a
couple days short of a month since the
last live stream which seems crazy it
doesn't feel like it's been that long
but I guess it has been and since the
last live stream I've been all the way
around the other side of the world
effectively down in Argentina visiting
my family I've come back we've done a
week and a half of shows at this point
all sorts of crazy stuff has happened
politically all sorts of stuff has been
going on with the David Pakman show and
here we are and yet we are back in the
same room and doing another live stream
so I'm glad to be doing this again hope
to get back to the regular schedule I
know a lot of people have been posting
tweets and Facebook messages there's a
thread on our reddit discussion forum
will there ever be live streams again
and I'm here to say yes there will yes
there will and this is the first one so
I will be taking questions from you I
will be talking about politics I'm also
going to be implementing a new sort of
paradigm when it comes to the live
streams as you know historically I
always start the live stream as I will
today with this graphic where I say if
this is your first live stream this is a
live stream that is live was assuming
that it's live number two I will take
questions the super chat super chat
questions and comments will be read
addressed answered if they warrant an
answer and then that's when I talk about
how new members and patrons will get
live thank-yous and shout outs during
the stream and you know sometimes we go
into like almost telethon mode with the
patrons and the members and the entire
thing and the reason for it is pretty
obvious which is things have been pretty
pretty tough lately for the show
financially because of what's been going
on on YouTube but I've been getting some
complaints right I've been getting some
complaints from people saying David you
know it's a bit too much talking about
paid
Rhian and membership during the live
streams you should instead mention it at
the beginning do some thank yous and
updates on how that's going halfway
through and then mention it at the end
and what a lot of people are suggesting
is that we'll get just as many new
members and patrons if I do that as
opposed to regularly go back and do
member thank-yous and talk about that so
I'm gonna try that today okay and we
will see if people are right that
actually by talking about membership and
patreon less we will actually get more
people to contribute so I will say a
very brief few words about what's going
on because a lot of people have been
wondering over the last month what's
going on financially and then I will
leave that topic until we are halfway
through so the big picture is david
pakman show in A funding crunch I am now
considering YouTube effectively done of
course super chats contribute towards
YouTube revenue but effectively we are
no longer considering YouTube ad revenue
from ads playing before our videos in
terms of making budgeting decisions for
the show because it's become too
unreliable we've lost about 80% of the
revenue and it's just it's just not
smart financially to count on that money
so there's basically two primary ways
that we are funding the show if you've
never heard this this this actually
isn't used to some people number one
direct memberships at david pakman.com
slash membership you drag that red dot
wherever you want or keep it where it is
click the red sign up button and then
you can become a member very easily if
you want a discount off of membership
you use the coupon code I voted 17 it'll
save you 40 percent real easy you'll get
the bonus show you'll get the commercial
free show now the other thing we've been
doing is trying to build up patreon and
we've built up we were so close to 2,000
patrons at the end of August and of
course on the 1st of the month
5 6 7 % of our patrons credit cards have
expired or get declined and we're back
down to now 1882 patrons the big news
with patreon is that we're adding
writing benefits to patreon effective
tomorrow and you can already see this
list
at the to five ten and twenty five
dollar levels there will now be bonus
show access full show access so it's no
longer just hey I throw a little money
on patreon and I don't get anything
there will now be both bonus show and
full show access through patreon and of
course we're trying to get 2,000 patrons
when we do that I will do an entire show
from the studio with my hair like this
we've been teasing it we get so close
and then the first of the month comes
and we get knocked down that's all I
will say about patreon and membership we
are not doing the big telethon today and
thus I won't mention it again but of
course I will do thank-yous half way
through the stream super chat super chat
is a great way to get me questions and
and comments because it can be difficult
to keep up with the regular chat and
it's another way to support the show
just to give you an example because it's
been so long since I did a live stream
just to give you an example of what
happens when somebody sends a super chat
we have one here we have a $6 and 66
cent super chat from zero one three two
one three two
who says David please if you played
destiny to with me this would be $25 a
month I swear I am aware of destiny too
I have not played it it would be very
very boring to play it with me because I
have no idea what's going on with that
game although I have friends great
friends great people absolutely the best
people who can play it and play it with
the best of them alright so I don't know
I not opposed to playing destiny to with
you in principle but I just don't think
that it would be very much fun okay so
tomorrow on the program we are going to
have a really great interview assuming
our connection holds because we had a
pretty big tech issue today with our
interview sort of system that runs on
skype but it is not just Skype I'm
hoping to speak tomorrow on the program
with
- Bryce who has a very interesting book
about what it was like to actually grow
up in the former Soviet Union it's a
really unique take not something we're
probably used to hearing too much a lot
of ideas of what it might have been like
to grow up in that certain those
circumstances in the in the former
Soviet Union but I think it's gonna be a
very very interesting interview and then
we also have we have been during the
vacation we released a number of
long-form videos and those were released
on YouTube and those have been on the
broadcast show last week and this week
and the reaction to them has just been
incredible and we still have one more
one was on today's program socialism has
never worked debunked that was the
subject of today's long-form video and
then as of right now and this of course
can change next Tuesday our our
broadcast show will have a long-form
video on voter suppression and voter
fraud ok voter suppression and voter
fraud and I think that that will also be
a very very interesting one and of
course these have already been made
available on YouTube the other thing
that's going on with the show really
interesting interviews coming up next
week right now and I always sort of
hesitate to give you the interview
schedule because interview so often get
moved around or the guest forgets that
they need to be on skype and they don't
even have Skype even though we've agreed
to a Skype interview where we can see
the guest or whatever but at least to
give you a sense of the types of
interviews were working on I'm scheduled
to interview Sean McFate who's a former
mercenary okay super interesting novel
that he wrote sort of a fictionalized
version of his work as a mercenary I
think that that will be very very
interesting we will also be speaking to
at the recommendation of the audience
Steve Leto or lead oh I'm not exactly
sure how he pronounces his last name
he's an attorney who specializes in
automobile related law so everything
from lemon law to warranty law and all
sorts of the stuff that we sort of have
a sense is really not working in our
favor
Steve Ledo Steve Leto we'll find out how
he pronounces his last name next week he
will be joining me and also this is very
exciting to me I recently read the the
novel dark matter by Blake Crouch who's
also by the way the screenwriter and
producer of wayward Pines he will be
joining me and I am a big fan of Blake
Crouch so I'm really really looking
forward to that I think that that's
gonna be a really really great interview
and this is not even this isn't even
officially on our calendar yet but we
have agreed on a day with Elizabeth
Kolbert Elizabeth Kolbert wrote the
great non-fiction book the sixth
extinction one of the books that
actually President Obama I believe once
recommended and said that he had read
himself and recommended to others and
Elizabeth Kolbert is scheduled to be
with us for a for a two-part interview
which I think is going to be absolutely
fantastic and that oh and also Ken
caldera who's an expert on ocean
acidification and when we talk about
climate change and we talk about sea
level and ocean temperature those are
only parts of what's going on and
actually as Elizabeth Kolbert describes
in the sixth extinction the ocean water
becoming more acidic is a really big
factor when we think about climate
change and and extinction of species
species above and beyond what's called
the background extinction rate so
there's gonna be a lot coming up it's
gonna be a very very busy September and
I look forward to having everybody with
us on the program
tomorrow I will be talking about Arnold
Schwarzenegger new sort of mission to
end gerrymandering or what we might know
of as political redistricting right and
it's so weird how in the Trump era
people who I would never say that's
someone that we can sort of Ally with on
some issues in the era of Trump it's
John McCain is making a lot of sense on
some issues Arnold Schwarzenegger
making a lot of sense on some issues
Mitt Romney making sense on some issues
even George W Bush and I've been very
careful not to normalize george w bush
but even george w bush actually making
sense on some issues so we will talk
about that on tomorrow's program also
some of you may remember that some of
you may not four years ago i was
featured in a documentary about bullied
LGBT teenagers who had tragically taken
their own lives which is a really really
serious issue and i was listed in a
montage of supposed dead gay teens by
suicide after being bullied and and it
was it was odd because of course i
wasn't a teenager at the time and i'm
not gay and I wasn't bullied and I was
alive at the time I hadn't committed
suicide and the clip sort of went a
little bit viral four years ago and then
it kind of went away and a couple days
ago a friend of mine sent me a message
saying hey you know that you're on the
front page of Reddit right now and I
said front page of Reddit I've been on
vacation I don't even know what's going
on went to Reddit and it turns out that
there was indeed a thread something like
this man once found out he was dead by
being featured in a documentary about
teen bullying or something like that
that resurfaced and drove an absurd
amount of traffic I mean absolutely
absurd amount of traffic to that video
and we'll talk about that a little bit
tomorrow and also we we sort of have a
sense of how being president has been
pretty good financially for Donald Trump
we talked about foreign dignitaries
coming to the u.s. and staying at
Trump's hotels but there's an even more
disturbing trend that USA Today of all
of all media outlets did a very
interesting investigation into USA Today
was able to track down and I'll talk
tomorrow on the program about the way
they did it
USA Today was able to track down
lobbyists and corporate CEOs that are
members of trumps golf clubs who by the
way have been spending time at Trump's
golf clubs at the same time as Donald
Trump has been on one of his end
golf vacations so initially we thought
well okay Trump spending all this time
at his Golf Club and it's expensive for
taxpayers because Secret Service has to
get set up there and that's funneling
money into Trump's coffers and Trump's
lazy and doesn't want to work it may
actually be even worse than that it
appears as though this may be a way to
buy access to the president and by the
way by access to the president in a way
that directly benefits the president's
businesses which of course supposedly
are in a trust right now but that
money's going to be there waiting for
him when he is no longer president of
the United States and this is incredibly
concerning and by every indication
completely legal there by the letter of
the law strictly speaking it's legal
there may be sort of more subjective
applications or interpretations where
what Donald Trump is doing is not legal
in a sense by receiving this money and
of course he would say he's never
influenced by what any of these
lobbyists or corporate CEOs tell him
after they've paid their hundred
thousand dollar initiation fee at his
club and he sees them there and they
talk to him he would never do anything
that would benefit them but of course we
realize that that's not the case and
Trump probably is doing many many things
that benefit those corporations that are
represented by CEOs and lobbyists at his
own clubs remember so it's bad it's
really really bad we'll talk about that
and also tomorrow it has been revealed
that Facebook sold ads to a Russian
company during the 2016 election which
if true and why Facebook would lie about
this unprovoked I don't really know if
true this would suggest or at least
raise the question of why Russia would
be buying political ads related to an
American political campaign on social
media websites and of course the
implications of that revelation are huge
and we're gonna dig into those tomorrow
I also plan to talk tomorrow although
with everything that's going on with
hurricane Irma hurricane Jose hurricane
Harvey and a lot of other news that's
breaking I don't know that I'll get to
this tomorrow but I wanted to talk about
the complete and utter Kay
that's happening because Donald Trump at
least at one moment today seemed to be
siding with Democrats on the issue of
the debt ceiling and when when I see
Donald Trump side with Democrats
I don't think oh he genuinely agrees
with Democrats on this particular issue
from a philosophical point of view I
assume like with most of Donald Trump's
positions that he doesn't fully
understand the issue and someone got his
ear and planted some seed of an idea
that has him thinking that this is his
position versus that being his position
and it's mere coincidence that he
happens to be at odds with Republicans
and seemingly more in line with
Democrats on the issue of the debt
ceiling every time there's some kind of
what we would call it a surprise from
Trump seemingly ideologically I have not
once been convinced that it really gives
us insight into Trump's true political
philosophy I don't believe he really has
a political philosophy I think that his
guiding principles are self enrichment
greed and delusions of grandeur which
inform a lot of his actions and
activities period and that that's really
the end of it so we'll talk about that
tomorrow as well and I've got a bunch of
other stories bookmarked but it's it's
never totally clear what we will and
won't get to particularly because
between the hours of 3:00 and 6:00 a.m.
a lot of things seem to happen so I used
to prepare like almost all but one story
for the next day's show the day before
I've stopped doing that because if I
prepare more than two or three stories
the day before I end up having to scrap
a bunch of them and wasting a lot of
time so I no longer am doing that let's
jump back into Super chats that are
coming in here okay zero one three two
one three two has sent a second Super
Chat for eleven dollars and eleven cents
you worry that monies will incentivize
you to forsake truth in favor of profits
also a news anchor in my town has the
same name how do I find out if
cross-check killed my vote on that
second question I have no idea I have
absolutely no idea how you find out if
cross-check killed your vote if two
people share the same name there should
be two P
with the same name that voted so that's
a start but beyond that I am not totally
sure on your first question am I worried
that the financial situation will sort
of incentivize the David Pakman show
to forsake truth in favor of profits you
know the whole point of trying to
replace the lost YouTube ad revenue with
patreon and membership dollars is so
that we can not worry about what it is
that we're saying in order to achieve
some level of financial success or
accomplishment that's the idea so I
actually think it's quite the opposite
when we have you know right now the
target is 2,000 patrons who are funding
the show fractionally a couple bucks at
a time no one person is going to be able
to influence the show because after all
they would only be one of 2,000 people
that are contributing and 2,000 people
will never agree on anything in other
words 2,000 people would not have any
unified set of demands that would be
able to influence the show so ash I
actually believe that if we were
depending on YouTube ad revenue which we
really aren't any more because there's
almost none of it left we might make
decisions against serious stories that
could be marked as not not
family-friendly by YouTube and thus not
make money we never did that but
conceivably it could happen I think that
we're going in the opposite direction I
think that we're going in the opposite
direction by virtue of trying to
separate our program completely from
dependence on YouTube funding okay J
wolf 1991 has sent the $20 super chat
with no question or comment thanks very
much
J wolf appreciate that Hobbiton has sent
the ten British pound super Chad it's
time we stopped saying Bush is just as
bad as Trump Bush was dumb but Trump is
literally empowering Nazis Bush at least
wanted to do good Trump's actions and
intents are far worse yeah I addressed
this a little bit at the beginning of
the livestream Hobbiton I have I
mentioned and I've said before compared
to Donald Trump George W Bush seems sort
of sober and
reasonable in his demeanor I don't agree
with his politics and I vehemently
disagree with many of the decisions that
George W Bush made so I've been pretty
careful and have frequently said just
because Trump makes bush look reasonable
just because Trump makes Mitt Romney
look reasonable just because Trump is so
out there that Arnold Schwarzenegger and
John McCain and Mitt Romney are coming
out of the woodwork and saying hey
Trump's off off-kilter
on issues a b c and d i don't want to
normalize people like George W Bush and
Mitt Romney and I just have to think
back to the campaign of george w bush
against john kerry to remember just how
out there george w bush is and the the
horrible and destructive decisions that
he made economically socially culturally
militarily I just have to remember Mitt
Romney and his binders full of women
strapping his dog to the roof of the car
while it had explosive diarrhea and all
of that stuff and the infamous please
proceed governor moment right I just
have to think back to that campaign and
I remember just because Trump makes
Romney look okay doesn't mean that
Romney is really okay right so so yeah I
think you're making a number of good
points there Juuko Virtanen has sent a
$10 super Chad our democracy is in
danger our best chance is to force
Congress to remove Trump and pence using
a general strike I created a Facebook
group called general strike to help
organize it you know Zuko
I've been thinking a lot about this and
I don't know if the best move is for
Congress to remove Trump and pence
number one I don't think it's a foregone
conclusion that if Trump gets removed
pence gets removed and that puts pence
in power I think on all issues other
than haphazard military action Donald
Trump is less dangerous than Mike Pence
and more impotent than Mike Pence and
less pragmatically
able to get things done however even if
Trump and pence go then it's Paul Ryan
and while Paul Ryan again seems much
more sober and nuanced than does Donald
Trump III don't want Paul Ryan in having
more power so I've said before and I
believe that it still holds true if you
are a progressive the best solution
might be the best solution might be that
a scandal rhythm ridden Trump stays
through a disastrous 2018 midterm
election and ultimately gets crushed in
2020 unable to accomplish almost
anything almost every day I move more in
that direction and reasonable people can
disagree and I'm open to hearing about
those disagreements but I think we have
to be very very careful what we wish for
Germain folder or Fedor Fedor has sent a
$10 super chat with no question or
comment I appreciate that
Yesenia Marino has sent a $2 super chat
can you do a deep dive on public
education that's a good idea I'm going
to make a note of that
Yesenia Yesenia who I believe is not
only a member but maybe also a patron
thank you a all-star triple threat
triple threat means super chat patreon
and and membership by the way if you
didn't know that very good idea public
education and really I mean we could
wrap in a lot of other elements to a
long-form piece on public education 0 1
3 2 1 3 2 has sent and $85 and 58 cents
super chat I believe one of the top five
super chats that we have ever received
just want it to be an even hundred
dollars and one cent keep doing what you
do we need more principled reasonable
people in the world also don't tell my
wife she's mad that I got pizza last
week
ok well listen I don't know your wife
and I would not pretend to tell her
anything but I appreciate the support
really really appreciate everybody who's
contributed but bye super chat ok a few
interesting reddit discussion forum
threads I want to point your your call
your attention to for people who don't
know the David Pakman show does have a
discussion forum and we now
over 4,000 of our viewers and listeners
I participate in the discussion forum
producer Pat participates in the
discussion forum I actually don't know
if producer Noah Ferguson is on reddit
but he should be that I can tell you
that I can tell you for sure and that
discussion forum is hosted on reddit so
instead of having you know installing
some kind of message board software on
our web site we are using the reddit
platform and you can shortcut to that
discussion forum at david pakman.com
slash reddit really really good
discussions that happen there a
discussion about the recent round of
Hillary Clinton attacks on Bernie
Sanders which I spoke about today other
deep dive long-form video suggestions
suggestions for how I might get onto the
Joe Rogan show which is something I've
expressed some interest in doing for
publicity
sake and some of our viewers said they
watched Joe Rogan and would be
interested in seeing me on there a lot
of really really good discussions on
Reddit and I know a lot of people sort
of hesitate sometimes to get involved in
in platforms like reddit because of the
trolling that takes place I can assure
you that we have a number of very very
well trained and professional moderators
some of whom overlap with our moderators
here on YouTube on the YouTube live
streams and I think that it's it's a
really great place to have political
discussion and and don't worry trolling
is not allowed no trolling allowed to
the extent that we see it so check that
out at david pakman.com slash read it ok
let me do now something I am making more
and more of an effort to do I although I
prioritize the Super chats during the
discussions during the live streams I do
want to make an effort to look through
and scan for questions and comments in
the regular chat and let me do that now
big Jasper's saying fake news David is a
gay dead teen that's very very
interesting let's see what other
questions we have in there have you
tried selling products on your show well
we have a parallel at david pakman.com
slash gear as well as coffee blends and
the like and bumper stickers I don't
know if you mean have I tried
pitching random products during the show
I don't think I have let's see what
other questions we have here but is this
really live
well yes Bella Hernandez asked if it was
live like can I read her comment right
now well I didn't then but I did now
because it is really live and it was at
the time although now you might be
watching the replay I don't really know
why does Lauren have a wrench next to
her name because she's a moderator that
seems to have been answered already what
other questions do we have here how do
you send money on here the dollar sign
at the bottom is the super chat button
David how are you I'm doing well thank
you I appreciate that what other
questions do we have that I can
specifically answer people talking about
reddit do I want to hear a joke not
really that's that's my honest answer
I'm not really interested in hearing any
jokes right now why do I pay attention
to the trolls well I think it's
important to know that they're there I
think it's important to know that
they're there but I don't know that I
pay any disproportionate amount of
attention and my east coast or west
coast of course a rap question I don't
think I'm either I I think I'm both and
I've enjoyed the rap stylings of both
I'm deliberately trying to sound out of
touch by the way now I have both East
Coast and West Coast 90s rap I'm a fan
of both East Coast and West Coast 90s
rap okay alright let me jump back into
super chat Christina asked when do I tip
eclis go to sleep and when do I tip
eclis wake up very very good in specific
question Christina always asks
incredibly specific questions I
typically go to sleep on weeknights
between 11:00 and midnight and I wake up
at 7:40 p.m. I'm sorry a.m. 7:40 a.m. at
least that's when I try to wake up
although sometimes I am up ahead of my
alarm clock
Bhalla five nine eight four has sent the
five euro super jet suit because should
coastal cities be abandoned because
we're only at one of two degrees Celsius
and storms will get stronger in future
Irma is registered by seismographs yeah
apparently equipment that typically
measures earthquakes is being triggered
by hurricane Emma listen I live in
Boston and I worry I mean what should
should I be living in Boston does it
make any sense to live in a city like
Boston or Miami or San Francisco or LA
or whatever given what we are
anticipating in terms of sea-level rise
I don't know I mean in in the
Netherlands they figured out how to do
the below sea-level thing and I hope
that it will be okay to continue living
in Boston but it does it does concern me
it is very very concerning
Jermaine Fodor has sent a ten dollar
super chat I just figured out how super
chat works I just wanted to tell you
that you're my favorite political
analyst well thank you very much
I appreciate that a couple other
questions from the regular chat who's
taller me or Kyle kolinsky I think Kyle
is taller I don't know how how tall Kyle
is most of the time I've been with Kyle
were sitting like at a restaurant or a
coffee shop so I don't know I think Kyle
is probably a little bit taller what
product do I use in my hair
I use I always forget what it's called I
think it's an American Crew American
Crew fiber hair wax or something like
that something like that I think is what
I think that's what I use okay I made a
promise at the beginning of this
livestream that I was not going to just
telethon throughout the entire thing and
talk about membership and patreon on the
advice of many of our viewers I
mentioned patreon and membership at the
beginning of the stream I will mention
it now about halfway through and I will
mention it at the end the test is will
just as many people sign up for
membership and page
if I only mention it three times spaced
very very far apart or not so far the
numbers are not looking that good
I will first briefly do a couple of
thank yous for patreon we are trying to
get to 2,000 patrons at patreon.com
slash david pakman show patrons now get
at the $2 level access to exclusive
behind-the-scenes videos as well as the
monthly patron only newsletter starting
tomorrow at the $5 level patrons will
get access to the world-famous bonus
show and that the ten dollar level
patrons will get access to the
behind-the-scenes videos the patron only
newsletter the bonus show as well as the
full show and at the twenty five dollar
level you'll get all that stuff plus
invites to support or only live streams
very exciting and I have to thank yous
to do amador has pledged five dollars a
month and Frank Witter has pledged $10 a
month my goal by the end of the stream
is 1900 patrons and again because I've
made this commitment for at least today
to only talk about patreon and
membership three times I don't know if
we'll get there but we are at 1884 we
started at 1882 I would like to be at
1900 by the end of the live stream now
as far as membership goes I also have
new member thank yous to make Lewis
Stein has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership and lee Ezell torres
has signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership if you want a discount you
can use the coupon code I voted 17 I
think somebody said oh yeah the last
Super chat I'm sorry the last coupon
code we did before the vacation stupid
Watergate 17 is still in the description
it still works
so if people want to use that it's an
even bigger even bigger discount ok
that's it and I will only mention
patreon and membership again at the very
very end of the livestream ok Clark one
two three four jumping us directly back
into Spanish Super chats and of course I
had
a two-week period visiting family of
mine in Argentina where I was mostly
speaking just Spanish and it was very
very exciting Clark sent a five
Australian dollar super chat saying da
beat TV yo en la portada that read it
estoy Arusha soda tea por finalmente
said Ernesto circuit of sexually ha
tambien como una situación illegal
okay so first oh yeah it's so by the way
this is Google translated English to
Spanish so it contains any number any
number of grammatic grammatical and
syntax errors so what Clark is saying is
that he saw me on the front page of
Reddit that he's proud of me for finally
being honest about my sexuality which is
some kind of joke and how is the legal
situation okay so jeez the legal
situation I hold on just one second I
just I have to block someone here there
we go okay so sorry for that distraction
so before the before the vacation I
notified you that we were threatened
with a lawsuit and we were threatened
with a lawsuit by a law firm that
basically does like mass demand letters
we were asked for many many thousands of
dollars and a nun for an image that was
used to year two over two years ago
about 26 months ago on the program in
the background right over my shoulder
during the show and we were being
demanded many many thousands of dollars
there were a number of copyright
attorneys in our audience who were kind
enough to get in touch with me and I
don't have an update on that yet other
than to say we have not yet been sued so
that's good news we've got that going
for us
despite losing 85% of YouTube ad revenue
but no we have not yet been sued and
that's a good thing every day that we
are not sued is a pretty good day right
okay actual justice warrior has sent a
$2 super check do you find
anything strange about Charlottesville I
don't know if that's a conspiratorial
type question do I find anything strange
about Charlottesville I don't know I
don't know by the way for people saying
that I had a hard time with the Spanish
there's a couple things going on number
one I was reading Spanish that was
translated by google translate from
English and it's riddled with
grammatical and syntax errors so I
really have to think through how it's
written because it doesn't make any
sense and also I speak Argentinian
Spanish it is not standard Spanish the
typical Spanish that you hear in the
United States is sort of central and
northern South American Spanish which
does have some differences Argentinian
Spanish is particularly different and a
lot of people it's very common that
people hear me speak and they they
assume that there's something wrong with
my Spanish and there may well be
something wrong with Argentinian Spanish
but it's just different it's just
different okay actual justice warrior I
don't know I I find a lot of things
disturbing about Charlottesville but I'm
not exactly sure what you're getting at
Jamal Swift has sent a $30 super chat I
keep reading that the electoral voting
system can't be changed what are your
thoughts well it's not that it can't be
changed okay it's not that the the
Electoral College that we have can't be
changed there's a couple different
things if we want to get away if we want
to go to popular vote nationally and
away from the electoral college you need
a constitutional amendment which
requires I always forget I believe it's
three-quarters of the states and
two-thirds of the House and Senate or
was it 2/3 of the states and now it's
three-quarters of the states and
two-thirds of the House and Senate I
believe and it's that that's not going
to happen okay so what other options are
there well there's something called the
national popular vote interstate compact
their national interstate popular vote
compact something like that and what
that would be is if enough states whose
sum total of electoral votes
are to 70 agree that they will award
their electoral votes to the winner of
the popular vote nationally they can
circumvent because states can decide how
to award electoral votes they can
circumvent the national electoral
college and instead basically make a de
facto popular vote that's one option
the other possibility that would give us
something very close to a national
popular vote in presidential elections
would be if states if all states decided
to award electoral votes proportionally
now it's not a perfect solution because
some states have so few delegates so few
electoral votes by virtue of a low
population that they would basically
have the same electoral vote
distribution whether one candidate gets
fifty one sixty one or seventy one
percent of the vote
right it depends on the state and the
population it wouldn't be perfect but it
would be closer so it's not that the
system can't be changed it's that to
truly change that the constitutional
level you need something that's just not
going to happen
aliyev an gotta has sent a ten dollar
super Chad black people and white people
who were never slaves are fighting white
people who were never Nazis over
Confederate statues that were erected by
Democrats but somehow it's all Donald
Trump's fault I hope that was worth $10
for you I've not heard anyone saying
that the fact that Confederate statues
are around is Donald Trump's fault the
entire the Confederate statues were
erected by Democrats involves I mean
this it's such a tired talking point
Olivia but there's been a drastic party
realignment in the United States and it
really doesn't tell us very much about
modern politics to say Confederate
statues were erected by Democrats and
the premise to the question I don't even
really understand so I appreciate the
super chat I don't know
I don't know what else I can really say
about them
christina has sent a $2.00 super chatted
do you have any shows you enjoy Game of
Thrones
okay so Game of Thrones has come up on
the broadcast show over the last ten
days I've only ever seen 15 or 20
minutes of a single episode of Game of
Thrones on an airplane and I barely
remember anything about it so I do have
shows that I enjoy many many shows very
very important shows I've recently
started watching Ozark the Netflix
original Ozark with Jason Bateman two
episodes in I like it I like it so far
very very good very very good program
big fan of Breaking Bad I like better
call Saul house of cards the Americans I
recently watched travelers season one I
don't know how many seasons there are it
was okay it was okay what other shows do
I like I really like Mad Men I watched
Sons of Anarchy it was okay
I could go on but those are so oh by the
way I really liked it's only like seven
or eight episodes ascension is a very
cool sci-fi show that I really enjoyed
because there's not that much good
sci-fi around and there's only like half
a season I guess they're calling it one
season but yeah those are a few of the
shows that I like ok let's do a
run-through of the non super chat people
saying the stream keeps freezing I don't
think it's on my end because my my video
uploader is working fine but I am seeing
the glitches as I monitor the stream so
it might be a YouTube issue what do I do
when I'm in Argentina mostly visit
family but this time I did also make a
side trip to Mendoza and did a little
wine tasting in the wine region there
and it was an interesting interesting
side trip I did a full bonus show by my
about my trip to Argentina by the way
you can check it out
let's see what other questions do we
have here I see you have art in your
apartment yeah finally got a piece of
art up like that people notice that
people saying anybody who speaks Spanish
realizes that it's not that I have
trouble with Spanish it's that I speak
Argentinean Spanish do I think a Kasich
Marco Rubio ticket would have beaten
Trump well no because a Kasich Rubio
ticket in the general election would
have been a second Republican ticket and
they would have split a lot of the
Republican vote so it might have done
better than Trump but it probably would
have guaranteed a victory for Hillary
Clinton which I would have been fine
with by the way okay let's jump back
into the super chat as there are any
number of super chats coming in fast and
furious J Woolf 1991 $20 thank you David
I messed up the last Super chat I've
noticed your subscriptions increasing
since I started following you following
you do you think these numbers would be
different if Trump were in office as we
all know Trump equals content listen I
did not vote for Donald Trump excuse me
just adjusting here but there is no
question that Donald Trump's election
has been very good for programs like
mine and we saw a significant
acceleration in new subscribers and
members and patrons and the whole thing
under Donald Trump so I think you're
right the numbers would be different if
if we did not have Donald Trump in
office Yesenia Marino $10 Super chat I'm
not surprised
about robert e lee's great-grandson it
was actually his great-great great-great
nephew I believe racism bigotry and a
lack of empathy is a big problem in the
Christian Church I say this as a
Christian so I know thank you for
calling them out okay oh so maybe you're
talking about something else we did a
story on the bonus show about robert e
lee's great-great great-great nephew
going on the MTV VMAs and basically
denouncing robert e lee and his past
and his church basically hated it and
said it sounded like he was supporting
social justice warriors and black lives
matter and he's quit he's quit and it's
absolutely vile and disgusting Wes
smoked $10 superjet daca how do you view
sessions as reasoning what's your
opinion on children young adults and US
workers
I've talked quite a bit yesterday and
today about daca so I don't want to fill
the livestream with it but what I will
tell us is on some issues you have to go
to the minutia to really understand
what's going on with some issues you
have to get out of the minutiae and go
to the the high-level right and I think
that that's where I have a problem Jeff
Sessions is trying to use micro
reasoning when if someone came to the US
as a kid before they were legally able
to make decisions about what they are
doing doesn't matter how old they are
now you can't in good conscience kick
them out now there are countries that
would I don't believe it's becoming of
the United States so I think that if you
came here if you have dreamer status if
you came here because your parents
brought you here and you were a kid you
should not be deported you probably have
very little connection in many cases to
the country you came from or at least it
wouldn't be the decision of the u.s. to
say you go back or it shouldn't be a bot
five five zero eight one has sent a
five-dollar super check David what do
you personally think should be done
about North Korea complicated issue I
want to propose something to you that
I've been reading more and more about
and that some people think is crazy at
first glance but actually in some ways
makes quite a bit of sense what if
instead of the current approach with
North Korea we went to North Korea and
we said hey you know what you're a
country we don't agree with your
politics we don't agree with
you know how you treat your people we
don't agree with any of it but rather
than taking action that would
definitively be terrible for the
citizens of your country we're going to
allow you a seat at the big-boy table we
are going to allow you to do some
research into a nuclear program you will
be allowed to have a nuclear program but
you've got to play by the rules you have
to allow inspectors in you have to what
else do you have to do you can't make
threats to use nuclear weapons against
other countries you have to tone down
the rhetoric maybe it would be
productive maybe it would be productive
and it would actually create a better
situation because if we actually think
about the reasons why Kim jong-un would
want nuclear weapons and why he would
make threats a lot of them are
indicative of a total you know
megalomaniac but at the same time there
are reasons why if he looks around the
world and he says let's how are other
countries that have nukes treated
compared to countries that don't I think
I want nukes I'm just floating it as an
idea and there's a number of foreign
policy analysts who have suggested this
and I think it's interesting I think
it's very interesting 0 1 3 2 1 3 2
making themselves the super Chad
all-star of today's live stream with
$100 and one cent super chat making I
believe the total contributions two
hundred dollars in two cents for the
evening stunning stunning how do you
know that Trump is the reason for your
show growing rather than YouTube D
monetization and other tangential
effects
well the accelerated growth of the
audience started right after Trump's
election and accelerated after Trump's
inauguration right November and January
D monetization started on March 31st
like it's like a marked in an imaginary
calendar in my head so the accelerated
growth of the show predated YouTube D
monetization okay Jennifer karein has
sent the $20 super chat I like the new
perks you were adding to patreon
subscribers are the
Herc's like supporter only chats for
those of us who are members too or do I
need to up my patreon him out Jennifer
listen you've done enough for the show I
would never tell you you need to up your
patreon amount that's that's on a
personal level but in addition to that
no we are offering a lot of that all
that stuff is going to be available for
members and for patrons assuming the
patrons reach the level that is
prescribed on patreon so it will be
members and patrons invited to the
Members Only livestreams we will be
doing the behind the scenes videos all
of this great stuff and it's very very
exciting very very exciting and that I
can tell you Clark one two three four is
chiming in with another presumably
Google translated Spanish super chat
another one at the five Australian
dollar level I am kind of liking these
these are clever clever in that they're
funny the beat can be a tooth honesty
honest a stream Labs but I could Google
nope things cleaned up or ciento the
daf-2 super chats then being get done
put a seesaw a social blade okay so
first thing Clark is suggesting that I
change my donations and run them through
stream Labs I don't even know what that
is stream labs donations let's see what
stream labs I don't know can you even
switch super chat to stream labs I don't
know how that really works I will look
into that very very interesting in
addition I just lost the super chat how
precise is socialblade clark is asking
yeah so socialblade is a pro is a
website where you can basically type in
any youtube channel and it will give you
information about that channel
everything ranging from new subscribers
views revenue all sorts of stuff let's
take a look how accurate is it my
instinct has always been that it's not
hugely accurate
I think what is accurate on socialblade
are the monthly subscriber numbers maybe
I think that that is pretty accurate
because when you look at it you see that
it really starts to go off the charts in
November of 2016 just as I mentioned and
even in February which like I mentioned
predates D monetization a lot of the
other stuff is not particularly accurate
including earnings are certainly not
accurate earnings also earnings it's
funny earnings appear to be based on
what YouTube channels used to make a
really long time ago CPM is of course
how much you make per thousand views has
have trickled down steadily and the the
estimates on earnings also don't account
for the YouTube D monetization so yeah
that's my thought that's my thought
about socialblade interesting tool
there's another one someone pointed me
to I think it's social rank comm which
is also a social rank is for Instagram
and Twitter okay anyway good question
Clark appreciate it always appreciate
super chats from Clark okay what else
did I have on my agenda today
a hurricane stuff listen I've been
getting back I don't know why anyone
would ask me about this but I've been
getting emails from people saying I live
in Florida and I saw what happened in
Texas with hurricane Harvey and I I
don't know that I would evacuate if
there was an evacuation order evacuate
if there's an evacuation order I am NOT
a meteorologist I am NOT a climatologist
I am NOT I'm not anything right I'm just
some guy who has observed what happens
when people don't evacuate I believe
that if you were told to evacuate you
should evacuate this is serious stuff
people die it's not good it's not good
evacuate and I've not been in this
situation and I know it's really easy
for me to say because I live in
Massachusetts where we get big winter
storms and you never are told to
evacuate
when there's a winter storm and what
else do we have we don't have
earthquakes here we don't really have to
deal with flooding we don't have
hurricanes I don't know I know it's very
easy for me to say but you can be damn
sure if I'm told to evacuate
I am evacuating and again I don't know
why anyone would ask me but I think that
that's what you should do
Ptah their beds or darbus has sent a $2
super chat with no question or comment I
appreciate that thank you very much 0 1
3 2 1 3 2 has chimed in with another $22
21 cent super chat making it an even 2
to 2:20 to read whatever question
follows this I'm a piece have a good
stream whatever question follows this I
don't know whatever I don't know what
that means does that mean from someone
else I'll do this I'll do another run
through the regular chat and see what
questions there are now people might
have are David and Pat a couple no boy
no Pat as far as I know exclusively
dates women as do I so Pat and I are not
a couple is Pat upstairs no Pat doesn't
live with me what other questions do we
have here I agree with your approach to
North Korea that's interesting that's
very interesting
David what do you make of the
possibility of agent provocateurs on
either side of the protests basically
police pretending to be protesters
escalating we are change had an
interesting piece on it
yeah I don't I let me talk about
Instagram winners in a second I don't
deny that agent provocateurs exist and I
also don't deny that there are instances
I've seen pretty compelling evidence of
police ratcheting up in order to justify
more oppression against protesters I
don't know if you have a specific
protest in mind so I wouldn't be able to
say for sure but that is I'm not I'm not
ideologically committed to saying that
never
no it definitely does happen definitely
does that does happen okay
what when have I announced the Instagram
winners they were announced on today's
programs so last week a viewer named
Patrick Ferrara sponsored five
memberships which required hash tagging
with david pakman show seventeen some
kind of image video graphic meme
whatever on instagram related to the
show could be caricatures of me or Pat
could be mashups or remixes we got a
bunch of submissions and the five
winners were announced today so you can
hear that on the podcast if you remember
or a patriot patron you can see it on
the full show and otherwise the the
standalone clip with those winners will
be going live tonight Stephen grayer has
sent a five dollar super chat David you
should look into using stream labs all
of the money goes directly to your
PayPal I'm gonna look into it I'm going
to look into stream lab after the stream
okay so I do appreciate the suggestions
okay
I've been good I have not been doing
telethon
David live streams I do want to thank a
couple other people who have signed up
for membership Robert Beattie eniac
Enoch I do not know how to pronounce
that has signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership thank you to robert who
now gets the bonus show and the full
show and the invitations to the members
and patreon only live streams and all
sorts of other great stuff thank you to
karen peters who has signed up at david
pakman.com slash live stream and latin
sadly I have no patrons left to thank
because it seems when I don't do
telethon style live streams not that
many people become patrons or sign up
for membership which is sad so if you
missed the beginning of the show the
idea was a handful of people said David
you know I love the live streams but I
don't love when you talk about
membership and patreon it's too much
like Home Shopping Network or you know
some kind of telephone what about just
mentioning at the beginning
middle and towards the end of the
livestream that you are thanking new
members and patrons and there's a target
for today it was nineteen hundred
patrons for example and I bet some
people suggested that you would get just
as many new members and new patrons as
if you talked about it throughout and it
does not appear to have happened I am
willing to continue testing this idea
it's great to have more time to do the
political content but so far it hasn't
happened and we are in a complex
situation when it comes to revenue and
believe me it's not for fun that I talk
about membership and patreon it's
because these are necessary revenue
sources so today the test was not hugely
successful it was not hugely successful
when it comes to not talking much about
those things let's do a couple other
Super chats gr has sent the $5 Super
chat gr making an appearance I was
wondering where gr was known for his
incoherent rants gr says let's talk
Pumpkins these how funny would it be d
to see the Trump nasty stomp out a
flaming bag of poop with his feet DS
love gr that would be funny I don't know
what it has to do with pumpkins of
course we are only about seven weeks
from from not Thanksgiving but rather
what's that thing called Halloween but I
don't know what flaming bags have poop
have to do with pumpkins but yeah I'll
look into that
Diego Moran has sent a $5 super check
what did you have against people that
voted for jealous Jill Stein and blue
states wouldn't a vote for her have been
more effective than a vote for Hillary
in a blue state effective for what I'm
not a green party guy and I thought that
Jill Stein was nutty nutty nutty so for
me when we got to the presidential
election of November 2016 by voting for
Hillary Clinton here in Massachusetts I
voted for the candidate that was closest
to my political beliefs did I vote for
Hillary Clinton in the Democratic
primary
no was I going to vote for Jill Stein no
I was not going to vote for
gee are sending another $5 super chat no
good light to put Trump in but carving
his face in a pumpkin then smashing that
pumpkin no pies just smashed pumpkin
love gr okay well you know I am NOT an
advocate of violence that I can tell you
that I can tell you and Clark 1 2 3 4
3rd super chat of the evening a tattoo
Australian dollar level Louis Motamedi
update twitch stream when so I am gonna
see Louis tomorrow tomorrow night Louis
and I will be taking in the season
opener of the New England Patriots a
Julian Edelman free New England Patriots
due to a a sad injury that has been
sustained by Julian Edelman and I will
ask him about the twitch streaming I
will ask about that yesenia Moreno has
sent a $2 super chat will you interview
non-political youtubers I don't know who
you have in mind I've interviewed and
then he Fantana from the needle drop
haven't I right he's been on the show I
know I know yeah
yeah he's been on the show right now I'm
doubt yes of course Anthony Fantino has
been on the show now I was doubting
whether it was a YouTube only thing but
yeah Anthony's been on at least twice
once we talked about streaming revenue
for musicians on things like Spotify and
I don't remember what the subject of the
other one we did and Lewis once
interviewed Anthony Fantana
the Internet's busiest music nerd send
me your thoughts offline as to who it is
that you would like me to interview and
I will absolutely look into it alright
that's it for this stream thanks to
everybody who contributed be a patreon
now with full member benefits on patreon
membership super chat the entire thing
I'll do another livestream soon